ich fühle mich in den letzten Tagen ein
bisschen komisch halloween ist jetzt
vorbei wir dürfen jetzt wirklich
offiziell in Weihnachtsstimmung sein
auch die Zeit umgestellt wurde ist es
schon um 17 Uhr stockdus da draußen man
fühlt sich einfach irgendwie
komisch und da braucht man etwas für die
gute Laune und deswegen packen wir heute
den vernasche die Welt Adventskalender
aus ich kenne vernasche die Welt ehrlich
gesagt nicht so gut ich habe immer
früher bei World of sweet Süßigkeiten
bestellt aber das muss ich jetzt hier an
dieser Stelle sagen die haben gefragt ob
sie mir einen zuschicken können und habe
ich gesagt ja macht mal also ne passt
auf ich bin hart und meiner Kritik sie
haben sich getraut und deswegen ist
dieses Video so ein ganz bisschen
gesponsert okay vernaschen die Welt
ehrlich gesagt erinnert mich das
vernasche die Welt Logo auch ein
bisschen an World of sweet aber es gibt
ja mittlerweile sehr viele Süßigkeiten
Anbieter ich glaube Montana black
arbeitet immer mit sugar Gang dann gibt
es vernasche die Welt dann gibt es World
of Sweets es gab noch sugar Fari war
einer der OGS ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch
noch einen sugar Fahri erinnert das ist
so ein Berliner Unternehmen gewesen
triggerwarnung in den nächsten zehn
Sekunden geht es um eine Spinne
nee das ist eine ganz linke Spinne an
meiner Kamera ja du da bleiben aber du
kriegst nichts von meinen Süßigkeiten du
kleine Spinner
in meiner du darfst da bleiben egal
werde machen
werde diese Woche und ich freue mich
vielleicht lernen wir da auch in
Brasilien ich habe das Gefühl die haben
sich hier von mir nicht ganz die
Bildrechte abgeholt denn ich sehe
wirklich aus wie diese fröhliche Person
hier vorne dran werde Teil unser
Community ja natürlich gerne
was haben wir denn hier golden ticket
ein golden ticket to New York habe ich
etwa herzlich Glückwunsch du hast das
goldene Ticket gefunden
vernasche die Welt bringt dich mit
deiner einer Begleitpersonen in euren
Traumurlaub von dem ihr schon immer
geträumt habt dieses goldene Ticket
bringt euch für sieben Tage nach New
York USA Flüge und hotelaufnahmen werden
komplett von uns übernommen meldet euch
bei unseren Team vergiss nicht so viele
Videos und Fotos wie möglich zu machen
und dieses mit uns zu teilen
hä okay ich bin sowas hier ist ein
goldenes Ticket von New York und hier
sind goldenes Ticket von Thailand und
goldenes Ticket für
Malediven herzlichen Glückwunsch du hast
das goldene ja wenn vernasche die Welt
das jetzt mit Absicht gemacht hat und
mir so mitteilen möchte dass sie mich
nach New York auf die Malediven und nach
Thailand mitnehmen wollen dann sage ich
tolle PR-Aktion Hand drauf wir machen es
ne komm jetzt müsst ihr also vernasche
die Welt jetzt habt ihr mir Hoffnung
gemacht weil Taylan und Malediven war
ich noch nie und New York würde ich
immer wieder gerne machen kommt es kann
doch nicht sein also es ist über also es
ist wirklich hier so formuliert dass ich
es wirklich gewonnen habe also geil wenn
es ein Fehler wird aus Versehen jemand
das da rein gemacht hat und die sich
jetzt denken scheiße aber ich sag's wie
es ist Leute ich habe drei goldene
Tickets hat sie jetzt ein vernasche die
Welt Adventskalender gekauft hat habt
ihr auch diese goldenen Tickets ich muss
das jetzt unbedingt klären aber ich sag
mal so ich habe sie fair gewonnen keine
Ahnung okay lass uns mal mit dem
Kalender weitermachen ja ähm leider mega
cute ne das hatten sehr süßen Charakter
ja okay und bekommt auch eine Schnur mit
diesem Kalender dass man sich den zu
Hause natürlich sehr toll aufhängen kann
lieben wir was kostet er wenn naschen
die Welt und wenn's Kalender sichere dir
die Chance auf den Gewinn einer Reise ja
du hast richtig gehört du hast die
Chance einen Trip an eines der
angesagtesten Reiseziele finden ist wenn
du in einem deiner 24 Tütchen das
goldene Ticket findest dann bist du der
glückliche Gewinner stell dir vor wie du
in New York in der Stadt die niemals
schläft mit einer Person deiner Wahl die
Lichter in Skylanders Leute ich habe
mich nur in einer Tüte das goldene
Ticket gewonnen ich habe drei Mal hier
das goldene Ticket bin ich wirklich ein
glücklicher Gewinner
okay was kostet denn der Adventskalender
aha 65 Euro
90 hier steht nichts mit einem krasseren
Warenwert also jetzt muss ich aufpassen
wenn ich auf die Malediven Fliege will
ich ja einen Beach body haben ne so
einen kleinen Bissen okay wir fangen
jetzt mal einfach an wir stürzen uns
rein jetzt ist nur die Frage dieser
Kalender ist natürlich komplett
durcheinander glaube ich brauche noch
einen für meinen Arsch im erdkanal ja
gut das überlege ich mir dann auf den
Malediven mit dem asmr-kanal die packen
einem noch zwei Schachteln von den
Klammern dazu dass man das halt dann
wirklich aufhängen kann nice Türchen
Nummer eins tut mir leid aber das geht
mir immer noch nicht aus dem Kopf
und endlich mal eins sehr praktisch wie
auch in dem adventsson-kalender dass man
immer so eine Erklärung zu seinem
Türchen hat high-to prank Cocktail
kannst du rausfinden welcher Geschmack
der hat Irland ah und hier oben steht
dann das Land aus welchem Land die Chips
kommt ah sehr cool Fakt der 6 Januar ist
der Women's Christmas Day und auch der
letzte Weihnachtstag an diesem Tag
erledigen die Frauen keine Hausarbeit
die Männer bleiben zu Hause nehmen die
Dekoration ab und bereiten alle
Mahlzeiten zu am 6 januar ist es auch in
Deutschland das drei Könige das ist
nicht Garnele
Brown Cocktail flavour potato chips ja
das ist doch ein Garnelen Cocktail aber
ich finde die schmecken eher wie es
sollted weniger
sehr sauer falls es wieder so ein Tag an
dem ich meinen Job liebe den bewahre ich
auf der ist super zum Nachfüllen ihr
könnt vergessen was ich heute Preise
zusammensuche bei Produkten die auf der
ganzen Welt verkauft werden die nebens
hin leckere chipsychisch nam Nummer zwei
in Tschechien Nummer zwei befindet sich
ein Fisch und das Land ist
Japan
[Musik]
Schoko lemonate
die randschleichen oder was das ist ein
Waffel Snack mit Zitronengeschmack und
Schokoladenfüllung ich würde auch sagen
lecker ist schon mega cute ne
also die äußere Waffe schmeckt richtig
nach so einer Eiscreme Waffel aber den
Inhalt verstehe ich nicht ganz
ist das die Schokolade das schmeckt
wirklich nach einer luftigen
Schokoladenfüllung und sieht auch danach
aus seht ihr das ganz komische
Konsistenz
ich bin nicht der größte zitronenschoko
Freund aber es ist ein interessanter
Geschmack muss gut auch in meine Boxen
reingucken ne nicht dass ich noch mehr
goldene Tickets übersehen hat Türchen
Nummer drei England was ist es hier
haben wir auf jeden Fall vollzeites
Produkte einmal der Boost und einmal der
double decker der Boost ist einer der
beliebtesten Riegel von Cadbury
Milchschokolade mit Karamell und
biskuitfüllung der doublejaker dieser
Riegel hat eine weiche knusprige Nougat
Oberschicht mit einer knusprigen
Unterschicht und köstlicher können
allerdings hä und ein kleiner
Weihnachtsfest es gibt immer zu jedem
Land einen kleinen Weihnachtsfest der
zweite Weihnachtsfeiertag wird in
England auch Boxing Day genannt dieser
Tag steht ganz im Zeichen der
Dankbarkeit also ich werde jetzt nicht
essen weil ich nach England fahre und
sie dort auch noch mal probieren kann
ich werde die aber in die verlosungsbox
reinpacken und die erste verlosungsrunde
ist jetzt schon vorbei seit gestern und
es haben Leute die Verlosungen äh die
Adventskalender gewonnen aber keine
Sorge in drei Wochen gibt es auf meinem
Instagram Kanal die nächste Runde ein
Adventskalendern und dann die da drin
mal gucken ob ich einen Zuckerschock
Nummer 4
Frankreich die packen hier full size
Produkt rein lutti Rollo sind leckere
Fruchtgummi Schnecken mit
Erdbeergeschmack viel Spaß beim endlosen
auf und Abrollen wer möchte hier Haribo
Konkurrenz machen wer traut sich
hier stehen arabische Buchstaben drauf
irgendwie denke ich dass es dadurch
halal ist Gelatine free natural flavours
sie sind ohne Gelatine deswegen haben
die nicht diese Zehe Konsistenz die
schmecken wie eine gesunde Variante von
diesen Haribos haut mich auch nicht aus
den zocken Türchen Nummer 5 was ist drin
das
soll Griechenland sein na gut ich meine
früher in Polen habe ich auch immer
schon Sachen gegessen die ist in
Deutschland gar nicht gab Cheater
sweetos knusprige Weihnachtsgrüße aus
Griechenland leckere cheetos Vitos mit
Kakao Creme Füllung ich dachte cheetos
sind cheetos weil das mit Käse ist die
sehen aus wie diese nougat-bikes
die schmecken wirklich eins zu eins wie
diese Nougat Cornflakes gefüllten Dinger
die man auch z.B bei Aldi oder Lidl oder
so kriegt
jetzt sind wir bei Nikolaus
ich lüg nicht ich habe erstmal Maus
gelesen es steht aber muss ach du lieber
Nikolaus
geht sogar nikolaus im Text ach du
lieber Nikolaus komm ganz schnell in
unser Haus habe so viel an Dich gedacht
hast du mir doch was mitgebracht oh das
sieht gut aus aus Argentinien das gibt's
nicht in Deutschland ne also ich habe
das noch nie gesehen das finde ich jetzt
irgendwie schade wenn ich dann nur so
ein bisschen vonnehme und da dann nicht
wirklich auf esse ich kann mir aber
genau vorstellen wie es schmeckt nach
Teig Schokocreme und Schokolade
Argentinien und dann mega also ich weiß
noch ganz genau dass die lila Kühe da in
den Alpen stehen ne es war einmal eine
lila Kuh Nummer 7 ähm Chips Deluxe was
ist die Weihnachtszeit ohne Kekse in der
Weihnachtsbäckerei wurden leckere
Cookies mit M&M Slee Schokolade für euch
gezaubert es kommt aus den USA aber ich
kann ja in demnächst mal hinfahren mit
meinem goldenen Ticket und noch mehr
davon holen guckt mal bitte wie die
aussehen expertation vs reality oder was
bessere Sachen oh
Nummer 8 ist groß
okay
Niederlande lace Chips mit Bolognese
flavour ich flippe aus und also ich habe
die mit Popcorn knusprige Waffeln mit
Popcorn umhüllt von zarter
Milchschokolade
die lassen wir mal wir probieren mal die
Bolognese Chips die Geschenke gibt es in
Niederlande schon am 6 Dezember das sind
Chips Bolognese vielleicht ein bisschen
[Musik]
das schmeckt echt nicht schlecht aber es
schmeckt einfach so krass nach Bolognese
immer komisch da möchte man hören noch
nicht ganz mitmachen okay vernasche die
Welt was hast du am 9 dezember zu bieten
wichtiger Tag
jetzt ernsthaft was ist das bitte für
ein Zufall aber weg
hier nobody the final the doggisches
makulieren
jetzt ein paar were Weg weiße Schokolade
mit dunkler Schokolade gefüllt meine
Brüder und Schwestern sind kreativ den
werde ich definitiv nicht probieren ich
weiß wie es schmeckt sehr sehr lecker
pack ich in die verlosungsbox natürlich
aber mich interessiert jetzt ein
Weihnachtsmarkt über Polen am Heiligen
Abend wird der Weihnachtsbaum
aufgestellt und anschließend gegen 17
Uhr eine weihnachtsoplade in Stücke
gebrochen und an alle Familien
Mitglieder verteilt jetzt true meine Oma
sendet uns seit ich denken kann jedes
Jahr weil sie in Polen lebt und wir in
Deutschland einen Brief mit einer
weihnachtsoblade zu und Esspapier was
man auch in der Kirche bekommt und es
dann in so einem quadratischen Stück und
das macht man so aber ein weiterer
Weihnachtsfest aus Polen man deckt
meistens für eine Person weiter den
Tisch die dann nicht da ist in Gedanken
dass falls jemand an der Tür klopfte
Hunger hat dass man ihn an Weihnachten
an seinen Tisch setzt und sagt bitte
schön hier hast du Kapusta i quas
Polen in Tierchen Nummer 9 also ich
glaube das ist hier gezinkt Woche
vielleicht eine Reise nach Polen nicht
schade
dass die schonde Nummer 10 Mexiko
Mexiko was
los bei mir ob sie freaky oder freaky
ausgesprochen werden entweder oder aha
okay also wir haben die ferriki fruits
drin saura Kausch für Groß und Klein ich
kam mir vorstellen wie das schmeckt ich
bin da jetzt nicht so süchtig hinterher
ne seht ihr das sind diese wie bei
Haribo weich gefüllt mit bunten Rand
freaky fruits kommt in die verlosungsbox
aber den Kalender leider nicht für asmr
auspacken können mache ich jetzt Nummer
11 im Stil von asmr
keine Sorge ich flüstere nicht um euch
zu erschrecken
der triggerwarnung es geht die nächsten
Sekunden wieder um eine Spinne also was
Spinne gesehen das ist mit dir los so
eine richtig freche Spinne hast du jetzt
so kurz dein Auftritt gehabt ja bis
jetzt stolz auf Dich 2 Sekunden fame
and so this cat you you
Liebe spinnen wir machen jetzt weiter ne
okay es ist okay für dich ja können wir
ja gut das ist mein atmr-auftritt
verpasst sage ich Dir jetzt noch mal
ganz ehrlich Weihnachtsgrüße aus
Frankreich traditionell feines
französisches Buttergebäck probiere ich
nicht ich kann halt nicht 24 Sachen
wirklich immer probieren ne weil sonst
tut mir am Ende der Bauchweh und dann
muss ich spucken und das wollen wir alle
nicht Nummer 12 Halbzeit die dritten
Chips schon wieder aus Griechenland die
Halbzeit wird heute mit knusprigen Chips
in einem mediterranen Hauch von Oregano
die schreiben Halbzeit ich glaube die
haben einfach eine Videos geguckt weil
die schreiben das genauso wie ich das
sagen würde ne Halbzeit hier die Chips
lasse ich jetzt geschlossen ich habe
jetzt zweimal Chips probiert ich werde
die ähm in die Verlosung oh guck hier
liegt sogar noch ein Chip Nummer 13
wieder Irland also von den Ländern muss
ich sagen dass man jetzt hier noch nicht
so viel um eine Welt herum ne Mars
Triple tree Dattel Rosinen und
erdnussriegel kombiniert mit
karamellstücken und dazu noch
eingetauchen beträufelt mit
Milchschokolade das ist ein
weihnachtlicher Maß das habe ich noch
nie in meinem Leben gesehen Gott wie
strange sieht ihr das das sieht Original
aus wie ein Pamela reif Fitness Riegel
und lustigerweise hat doch irgendwer
diesen Vergleich gemacht zwischen Mars
und Pamela Riegel wegen dem kugelgrün
Zucker und so ja also den muss ich
probieren
der schmeckt eins zu eins wie diese
gesunden Fitness dattelriegel Pralinen
von den ganzen anderen Marken ich habe
das Gefühl dass das so ein scherzprodukt
von Mars ist als Antwort auf diese
kokosblütendebatte als Pamela reif dann
gesagt hat ja wenn eine Maßregel stecken
keine guten Produkte drin und die so
hoch my Karamellsoße wir haben hier
double Paste Erdnüsse und so drin ja es
ist interessant ist es wirklich
interessant ist macht mir aber gerade
viel zu fertig dass das jetzt so ein auf
dattelbasis Riegel ist Nummer 14
Brownie la casitos das kommt aus Spanien
lockere milchschokoladenkuchen mit
fröhlich bunten lecker casitos im
Inneren [ __ ] in die verlosungsbox wieder
ein neues Land oh mein Gott ich liebe
diese so sehr oh die Liebe ich oh mein
Gott
diese schaumbonbons schmecken nach
fruchtiger Banane
Bananengeschmack ist jetzt nicht mein
Favorite aber das sind diese die es auch
bei Ikea gibt das sind einfach die
besten Haribo Gummibärchen Zeugs was es
gibt und die sind sogar vegan und
Fairtrade also Leute da könnt ihr doch
nur zuschlagen meine Damen und Herren
Nummer 16 schon wieder tschüss
wir sind wieder in der USA und haben
hannib Barbecue Barbecue im Winter wir
machen es möglich leckere Kartoffelchips
mit dem süßen Geschmack von Honig in
Kombi wir brauchen Barbecue nee wir sind
schon wieder Chips zum vierten Mal
gibt's keinen anderen salzigen Snack 17
andere salzige Snacks werden halt Nüsse
Salzstangen mehr fallen mir nicht ein in
Nummer 17 ist aber dagegen
Finnland mit fizzy poppen uh sauer
sprudeln 'ne Colaflasche mit Bubblegum
Geschmack die spare ich mir weil ich
möchte jetzt nicht eins aufmachen sagen
ich mag keine Bubblegum und dann liegt
das hier rum deswegen packe ich das in
die Verlosung Nummer 18 Karat
Chris be crun
ch Häschen
der Cadbury crispy Crunch Riegel es ist
einer der beliebtesten Regel kann er das
finden wir probieren
[Musik]
ich dachte der hat die Konsistenz die
bei uns die krokanteier zu
Weihnachtszeit aber der hat einfach so
ganz knuspriges Karamell ich habe das
Gefühl der füllt nur meine Zahnlücken
ich habe ein ganz komplett neuen
gebissabdruck geschmacklich okay für die
Kanal ja nicht beleidigen aber ist okay
so wir spülen dann mal runter mit dem
nächsten Türchen Nummer 19 Südafrika da
sind wir jetzt mal wieder lang gereist
Mini cheddas fruit Chutney flavorite
Snake lass dein Inneres käsemonster los
und genieße knusprige Kekse egal wann
und wo relativ kleine Packung und ich
werde jetzt auch nicht aufmachen weil
käsecracker doch doch so sieht der Chip
aus er riecht auch wie weniger
wow eigentlich mag ich kein Käse
Geschmack oder sonst so ja so
Käsegeschmack finde ich bei Chips und so
salzigen Steaks überhaupt nicht gut aber
das hier schmeckt er wieso Essig mit
Käse
ich glaube das ist dieses food Chutney
sehr lecker
als Weihnachtsbäume finden sich hier
Affenbrotbäume guavenbäume oder
drahtannen ich finde das immer so lustig
die Vorstellung des Weihnachten dass es
da nicht kalt ist sondern irgendwo ganz
warm und man da auch Weihnachten feiert
wir sind in den 20ern angekommen mein
Bauch merkt es langsam und wir sind
wieder in Japan sind
Interesse mit weißer Schokolade
ummantelt KitKat Cheesecake und gibt
Gott ich möchte wissen wie sie den
Geschmack von Käsekuchen in dieses
KitKat reingepresst haben sieht wirklich
sehr unspektakulär aus also ich muss
jetzt nicht wie ein schmecken sollte
aber das schmeckt einfach nur Vanille
Licht okay
20 Brasilien meine Damen und Herren da
sind wir wieder Erdnussbutter Tor ohne
Karamell und knusprige Erdnüsse
überzogen von einer köstlichen
Schokoladenschicht aber sieht aus wie
eine dunkle Schokoladenschicht Sneakers
hat ja an sich so eine Marshmallow
Schicht Karamell und Erdnüsse da
irgendwie zusammen gemixt und dann
Schokolade drumherum das hier hat aber
keine Sonne Marshmallow Schicht
besser du bist nicht du wenn du hungrig
bist das ist einfach der Snickers ohne
diese marshmallow-schichten
meine Figur lecker alles warum wird in
Deutschland nicht die Variante verkauft
mit nur Karamell und Erdnüsse das ist
richtig lecker 22 wieder Mexiko das
werden moonpie aber es ist ein Mammut
und sowas der Mammut ist so ein
Marshmallow Keks mit Schokolade
überzogen kenn ich schon Rix xx
fruchtiger Kausch mit den Geschmäckern
von Wassermelone orange und Waldfrucht
da steht drauf Chopper barita die
anderen Typen fühlen sich an als ob da
Pulver drin wir haben das auch also das
ist Wassermelone
einfach so machen
wahrscheinlich ne
ich finde es komisch ich glaube die
haben sich ganz verstanden was soll denn
hier dran ein Kauspaß sein
es ist ganz cool tschüss Nummer 23 unser
vorletztes Türchen ich hoffe wir haben
jeden Tag die Zähne geputzt denn
wir sehen schon am Ende des Tunnels
nein kannst du wirklich sehr wichtig
Leute zweimal am Tag oh hier sind wir
dann wieder im brasilienbrasilianer du
die wissen was gut ist hab schon viel
von Oreo gesehen aber noch Schokolade
geht nicht mehr Oreo Keks mit
Marshmallow Creme gefüllt und zarter
Schokolade umhüllt ja okay wir probieren
den uh sieht der perfekt aus oh das muss
man erstmal hinkriegen ne
[Musik]
also so ähnlich ehrlich das hat schon
gar nicht mehr mit dem Oreo zu tun
schmeckt ganz interessant aber würde ich
mir ehrlich gesagt nicht noch mal
nachkaufen ich bin ehrlich zum Glück
habe ich nicht jedes Türchen probiert
denn jetzt sind wir bei der 24 und ich
habe langsam genug vom süßen
so mein Leben
20 Türchen im weihnachtstürchen oh
Brasilien schon wieder Brasilien also
einmal sicher gehen nee nee nicht noch
einen Kreisel all I want for Christmas
ist die aufregenden Kombi aus zarter
Milchschokolade und dem Geschmack von
leckeren Erdbeerschaum aus
julskum am 23 Dezember stellen die
Schweden eine Schüssel Milchbrei vor der
Tür um sich bei den Wichteln für die
Unterstützung bei den
Weihnachtsvorbereitungen zu bedanken ich
gehe jetzt mal ganz stark davon aus dass
Brasilien also dass das sich
verschrieben wurde denn das Wort Joolz
kommt klingt mir eher Schwedisch und sie
sagen ja auch schwedisches
Weihnachtsfest also das letzte Türchen
kommt aus Schweden wir gucken noch mal
wir checken hier nach woher kommst du
Malmö natürlich und das ist Schweden
Schweden was soll los ein paar
schluderige Fehler habt ihr schon
gemacht ne was sollen die Schweden von
euch denken man boah was kommt da für
ein weihnachtlicher Duft raus
boah und jetzt gucken wir mal dass
dieses Schulz gekommen ist interessant
ich weiß nicht ob ich sie mir wieder
kaufen würde aber die hat schon ja so
ein interessanten erdbeerrigen Geschmack
und sie sieht ehrlich gesagt ganz cute
aus ja was sagen wir zu diesem Kalender
erster Gedanke ein bisschen zu viel
Chips also gibt es nicht auch andere
salzige Snacks außer Chips bei den süßen
Sachen sehe ich eine ausgewogene
abwechslungsreiche Auswahl und vom Preis
65,90 durch 24 sind 2,74 € pro Türchen
2,74 €. ich würde den Preis so bei 2 10
das Türchen schätzen 60 sind sie dann
halt noch die Verpackungskosten und
sowas weil man muss ja ehrlich sagen ne
diese Verpackungen mit den Stickern
drauf und so das muss man halt per Hand
einpacken und das weiß ich auch dass das
dann nicht einfach so mal eben erledigt
ist und das Zeit braucht deswegen würde
ich sagen ja dieser Kalender ist zu
empfehlen aber vernasche die Welt wir
müssen uns hier noch mal unterhalten ich
habe nämlich drei goldene Tickets wer
bereit zwei Stück zu verlosen und ein
selber zu behalten wenn man mich jetzt
hier nicht in die Irre geführt hat lese
ich wenn du in deinem einem deiner 24
Türchen das goldene Ticket findest bist
du denn der glückliche Gewinner nicht
sag mal so ne wir können immer noch eine
Reise gut gebrauchen oh New York zur
Weihnachtszeit ja vernasche die Welt
also ich schreibe jetzt mal dem Support
und sag einfach dass ich drei Tickets
habe ne ja und dann klären wir das mal
und jetzt sagen wir mal Tschüss zu
dieser Spinne tschüss
ich